- We're going again?
- Yes.
(audience laughs)
You're welcome.
- [Garth] Oh yeah. (laughs)
- Oh boy, another one of your
daughters is embarrassed.
- Aerosmith!
- Aerosmith.
Now.
(audience applauds)
I am a hu, I thought I was
gonna marry Steven Tyler.
(audience laughs)
I was like, yeah ka ka ka kow!
Like all, it's like everywhere.
I was like, I had a fan in my bedroom.
I was like, yes, I was, yeah.
You gotta have Aerosmith's song.
- Oh, I showered with him.
- Oh wait, you covered the Fever.
- Yeah, we covered the Fever.
- Yeah!
But we were playing the last--
- Did you say, I showered with--
- I showered with him.
(audience laughs)
So we're playing the last
play at Cha, Billy Joel.
They're getting ready to tear
down Chase Stadium, New York.
And I go out there and I'm late anyway,
and they have just the baseball showers,
and I'm in their showering,
getting ready for the show.
And I had soap, my eyes
and look around and there's Steven Tyler.
He's showering too.
"Hey, how you doin'?"
(audience laughs)
And so it's just, it was, how
many people get to say that?
- Ah, no,
(audience laughs)
well, who knows?
Who knows?
He's rock and roll, I don't know.
- Beautiful cat at the
end of the day, yeah.
- You might not be so special, Garth.
(audience laughs)